first of all i keep getting distracted
by your background because
you say that you're in sort of a rural
part of england
and it looks like you're on the set
of a quaint agatha christie
you know what i mean i just keep it
looks like soon they're going to gather
you all in the room that you're in
and try and figure out who the murderer
is it's actually
it is actually a backdrop it's not real
behind it is palm springs where i really
am and it's eight in the morning and i'm
drunk on whiskey
okay all right okay yeah
it's so it's i'm staying at a friend of
mine's house and it is really beautiful
and i do feel a little bit like i'm in
agatha christie or something
yeah i'm just suggesting that you might
want to murder someone
while just because it's the perfect
place to do it
i agree i agree um you know i was
thinking about you've done
uh i want to talk about relic but i was
just thinking today about
you've done so much good work and you've
shown up in in so many good projects and
i was trying to think of the first time
i saw you
and was like who's that i remembered you
had a a big break
in uh what was it was it notting hill
was that
was that one of your early roles that
you were in yeah it was really one of my
first jobs and i
uh i was so delighted because i got this
part and
um i you know it was a small part but i
was called the perfect girl that was my
character type that was my name i didn't
actually have a name i was just the
perfect girl
i was never an actor but i did go to one
audition once for something for
i think it was the henson company or
something there was some show that they
were looking for and they said we have a
role you'd be perfect for
and they sent over sides and there were
two characters and they didn't tell me
which one
was who for who and the two characters
were
the hunk and the geek
and i remembered reading the description
of the hunk
and then i remembered reading the
description of the geek and it was like
this tall
gangly goofball isn't exactly a winner
with women
but he's such he's so silly that no one
takes him seriously and i went
oh okay i get it
i'm not the wrong i i once had a part
where
they they said i only had like a couple
of lines i was playing a publicist again
i didn't have a name i was just the
publicist i had a couple of lines
and then they said and i was like okay
well that's fine i'll do the part and
then they
they they rung up all excitedly my agent
saying they've added to your part
there's some more you know it's there's
another whole scene and i was like oh
god and i
i fleeing through desperately trying to
find the rest of the park but i couldn't
see it anywhere and finally in the sort
of small print
scene description i found one line that
said
uh the publicist is hogtied and gagged
in the corner
that's it that was the great new
addition to my role
great well hey no lines to learn so you
have that for you